so you how did you end up then
performing this uh or you went to a
concert and what happened yeah well I
got a text message from my friend saying
I'm with two I'm with short and uh we're
about to go on stage he's going to let
us sing two on stage with him
and uh I was like well I'll be right
there and um
I was as it happens at a very important
meeting but I was like this is this is
more important yeah
um I wasn't sitting around doing nothing
yeah sure so no you were no you were
very busy right when the text came in I
got pulled away did too short was
ready to go right and I had the lyrics
ready to go I was ready for this moment
actually where I was was downtown seeing
a Tim and Eric perform live at the at
the Nokia live Center which was amazing
okay amazing yeah and um
so I realized I had to get over there
there's a story that goes with us
I'm telling it now
[Laughter]
it's the story I'm now telling ah so
well then I will prepare myself we're on
the same page yes yes
so you get this message this important
text I realize I have to get there
pretty quickly to the Sunset Strip the
Key Club and I happen to cab downtown
off of a very busy Street downtown the
Figueroa which is like a lot of traffic
going both ways I get right I get in the
that one yeah I get in the cab and uh
the guy says to me hey I have to get
some gas can you can you hang with me or
do you need to get another cabin I go
I'm kind of in a hurry can you take me
to my car
I was parked downtown I said can you
take me to my car before you need gas
and he goes no I need gas now
so I go okay I'm gonna get out I got out
he drives off and I realize I left my
phone in the car
go to commercial
how does it all turn out we'll be right
back no it's a real Cliffhanger at this
point that's our season closer yeah I
don't think it's gonna get better from
here I think that was like you left your
phone that's a panicky moment the cab
starts to drive away what do you do so
he does a U-turn he goes down Figaro and
turns around so I go okay I have to get
in front of his car I have to stop him
so I run out in the intersection there's
a lot of traffic I kind of wait for a
window I find an opening I get in front
of his car and I'm going like this and
I'm you know communicating to him I'm
the guy that was just in your car
something's wrong stop he blows by me
right and so now it's like a nightmare
yeah and I instinctively just did some
backstory I have gone to two workout
classes with a friend of mine recently
in case you were in case you were
confused about the DraStic difference
am I a physique
so I instantly I instantly start chasing
him and uh you know just to give you a
sense of like the how fast it was going
here's him driving and this is me going
as fast as I can closing the gap
like this is me that's how far he was
and I'm like going as fast as I can
really it's a riveting reenactment right
there
that was like watching Terminator 2 yeah
just in case you want a promo spot for
tonight's episode Conan in there
tonight's episode
[Applause]
because that's your running now and
you're a famous person I don't mean to
you know famous person
I couldn't believe I was running either
I was like I'm famous what am I doing
I am like we're doing this myself people
are probably wondering why is Michael
actually some people were shouting at me
shouting at you or shouting my name at
me yeah and I spat my gum out I had gum
I spat it out like an action movie
I'm chasing I'm really pushing here I'm
going as fast as I can I closed the Gap
and I I take out my car keys and throw
them at his car I did
I did which I realized might have been a
little crazy he probably thinks he's
getting shot at yeah but he must have
seen me in his rear view and for some
reason he was like trying to get away
from it if you do this again to the king
I mean do that full on out it's just
it's scary when you do okay
I didn't have this mud but
I get to his car I slap the car and I
got my phone and got the phone and um I
was catching my breath for like the next
hour I'm sure she said people were
yelling your name on the street you must
get recognized a lot you've had a lot of
success your your athletree been in a
lot of big movies do people know who you
are right away more often than people
say to me are you Michael Sarah they say
are you Jesse Eisenberg that's not a
joke
I'm Jesse Eisenberg okay I know what's
tonight's episode yeah do you look that
much like Jesse Eisenberg
a picture of Jesse Eisenberg
on the right
you know where people get so what do you
do when people come up to do they really
do they people say you know you were
amazing in Zombieland
and I say then you got to see
Adventureland
laughs